- All right.
You guys are up first.
Who's gonna play,
and who's gonna guess?
- All right,
you let me chill out last--
I think I might go to work
here, we'll see.
- Okay.
- All right, there you go.
So we're gonna put
90 seconds on the clock.
Your first instrument
is gonna light up now.
- Okay.
- Uh...
[high pitched recorder notes]
Wait.
[recorder melody]
♪
- "Mary Had a Little Lamb"?
"Twinkle Twinkle Little Star."
- Thank you
- Very nice!
- All right!
- Piano is lit up.
- Oh, oh, wait.
That doesn't count!
We didn't know, we didn't know,
we didn't know!
- Jesus.
- It's so low!
[upbeat piano music]
- It's an '80s earworm.
- Ah, I don't know. Can I pass?
- You can pass.
You want to pass?
- "Come On Eileen"?
- Yes! Yeah, yeah!
- Never give up!
- I just got it!
- Oh, my God, an accordion?
Oh, no. Oh, God.
- Do you know how to play
the accordion?
- There's a first time
for everything.
Uh...
- Soul.
[accordion music]
♪
- Uh!
I don't know, skip.
- No? Okay, okay, that's okay!
- Next! I'm so sorry.
- Sounds good, whatever it was.
- Yeah, yeah.
'70s hit?
[funky kazoo tune]
- "We Are Family!"
- Yes!
- Yes, very nice!
- What?
- [laughs]
[buzzer]
all: Ah!
- That was great! Josh!
- Good job, you killed it!
- What was the jam
on the accordion?
- That was "Stand by Me."
- Ah, of course, "Stand by Me."
- I should have gone
some of the chorus.
- I could've done better.
I could've done better.
- Josh and Alessia,
you have the lead,
but Joseph and Chance,
it's your turn now
for random instruments.
Who's gonna play
and who's gonna guess?
- You should play.
- Joseph is going to play,
and you're gonna guess,
right? Now here's the deal.
You got 90 seconds.
Get it on the clock again,
90 seconds.
Your first instrument
is gonna light up now.
[cheers and applause]
- What?
I've never played this. What?
- Steel drum.
And it's a stadium anthem.
- Rhythm, rhythm.
[steel drum tune]
- "Another One Bites The Dust!"
- What in the world?
How did you get that?
- Yeah!
- How could you get that?
- Pass, pass, pass.
- Keep going. Another light.
Right there, behind you.
- Right there--guitar.
- [laughs]
So, okay, uh...
[classic rock and roll music]
- Yeah!
- Uh--
[plucking melody]
- Oh, um, "La Bamba"?
- Yeah! My gosh!
How do you know
how to play "La Bamba," dude?
- What? This is not fair!
[laughter]
- Groban got the piano.
- This is slanted.
- All right, here we go.
- Rhythm, rhythm.
[flat tuba tune]
- '70s disco.
[humming in rhythm]
- What?
- Do it again. I like this.
[flat tuba tune]
♪
- Oh, "Y.M.C.A."
"Y.M.C.A."
Keep going, one more!
Holidays!
- Holiday favorite. Here we go.
[maracas shaking rhythmically]
- "Jingle Bells!"
- This is great!
- Dude, one more!
- Five seconds! Five seconds!
'80s dance hit!
[didgeridoo stuttering]
- [laughs]
[buzzer]
- If you guess that--
if you guess that--
if you guess that,
I was like, yo.
- I don't know!
- Come on back, buddy.
- That was--
[didgeridoo stuttering]
- What song were you playing?
- What was it?
- "Funkytown."
You couldn't tell? Come on.
[laughter]